this video is sponsored by ag1 use the
link in the description to receive a
free one-year supply of vitamin D3 and
K2 and 5 travel packs with your first
purchase also for those interested my
new audiobook millions of little threads
is now available on Audible in addition
to the pursuit of Wonder website as well
as on Amazon as an ebook and paperback
links for those will be in the
description as well
life is short that's what people say for
most of us when we hear or consider this
it compels us to take more risks to get
more done to move faster to see more
places and meet more people to acquire
new things and Achieve new heights of
Social and career status
after all we only have so much time left
before time is gone forever
but perhaps for this very reason that
our time is limited and may be short we
should often take this phrase to mean
the opposite since life is short we
should slow down we should simplify
[Music]
many of us at least at some point have
wanted an extraordinary life a lifestyle
in which the calendar is always full and
everyone wants us to be somewhere doing
something where we have tons of friends
and contacts things to do places to
visit new items to acquire new social
levels to achieve perhaps this ideal
came from childhood when we were
conveyed that our sense of self-worth
was validated only by our display of
extraordinary Scholastic achievement
perhaps it came from the particular
culture through which we were programmed
Perhaps it is in our own personal nature
Perhaps it is all the above or something
else entirely
whatever the origins this idealization
can compel many of us to pursue these
sorts of Highly active highly
consumptive lives none of which is
inherently bad but likewise none of it
is inherently good what is bad however
is not knowing the difference for
oneself and not living accordingly
transcendentalist philosopher Henry
David Thoreau wrote I do believe in
Simplicity it is astonishing as well as
sad how many trivial Affairs even the
wisest thinks he must attend to in a day
how singular an affair he thinks he must
omit when the mathematician would solve
a difficult problem he first frees the
equation of all encumbrances and reduces
it to its simplest terms so simplify the
problem of Life distinguish the
necessary and the real probe the Earth
to see where your main Roots Run foreign
is often regarded as one of the most
valuable things it isn't really what's
valuable is our perception of it how we
handle and consider it having more or
less time makes no difference if the
majority of it still isn't spent and
experienced well
stoic philosopher Seneca wrote it is not
that we have a short time to live but
that we waste a lot of it life is long
enough and a sufficiently generous
amount has been given to us for the
highest achievements if it were all well
invested but when it is wasted in
heedless luxury and spent on no good
activity we are forced At Last by
death's final constraint to realize that
it has passed away before we knew it was
passing
so it is we are not given a short life
but we make it short and we are not
ill-supplied but wasteful of it life is
long if you know how to use it
the philosophy of stoicism is a very
useful school of thought to refer to and
draw from when considering these
Concepts simplifying one's life and
using one's time well
fundamentally the stoics argued that the
individual should strive to reduce all
dependency on unnecessary externalities
wealth material items Fame control over
other things and people and so on
almost nothing material is needed for a
happy life for he who has understood
existence wrote stoic philosopher and
Roman Emperor Marcus Aurelius
instead one should strive to focus their
time on fulfilling their
responsibilities and work cultivating a
command over their internal domain and
preserving the remaining time for
philosophically focused Leisure only
enjoying the fruits of one's labor if it
comes while not being motivated or
affected by it
although we don't necessarily need to
arrive at the exact same conclusion as
the stoics it is at the very least a
good place to start
in order to see time clearly and
determine what we believe is a valuable
use of it we should at least
conceptually strip all unnecessary
spending of it away and only put back
what we truly want and need
in the 17th century French philosopher
Rene Descartes provided an analogy in a
second edition of meditations on first
Philosophy for a sort of thought
experiment that he had conducted in
order to determine only what he could
know with absolute certainty to be true
in the analogy Descartes suggested to
imagine that you have a basket of apples
you're concerned that some of the apples
might be rotten and the rot will spread
to the other fresh apples the only way
to ensure that this doesn't happen is to
empty the whole basket inspect each
apple for rot one by one and then only
place back the fresh apples
again Descartes used this to illustrate
his process of doubting empirical and
ontological beliefs but the same thought
process can also be applied when
considering how we should spend our time
how we choose to spend our time when we
have a choice is likewise also a belief
it is what we believe about how life
should be lived
but in truth how often do we actually
inspect the apples of our life how many
of ours are rotten right now how much
has and how much will the rot spread if
we don't at least on occasion empty the
basket to check
a key factor to all of this to not only
understanding how one wants to spend
their time but also successfully
executing on what one determines is
somewhat paradoxical it is both a
driving force behind the avoidance of
doing what we want and what we know we
should do and the solution to doing what
we want and know we should do
the problem and the solution is boredom
the compulsion to do things all the time
be it filling up our life with ceaseless
desires filling up our schedules every
week with plans and events or filling up
every quiet moment with the noise of a
phone or computer or video game or
whatever else is largely driven by our
effort to avoid boredom both the feeling
of boredom and the feeling that others
see us as boring but it isn't boredom
that we are allowed to think and it is
through boredom that we will discover
great comfort Focus authenticity and
productivity
when we are not compelled to fill our
schedule with anything and everything in
order to Simply avoid boredom or seeming
boring when we are not compelled to
satiate the slightest intimation of
boredom with a phone or console we will
instead begin to more often do the
things we otherwise put off but actually
want to do and work on like most things
boredom is relative if let's say one has
no plans on a Friday night and they are
limiting their phone or video game usage
or whatever else writing that next
chapter of that book or writing out that
business plan for that business idea or
journaling about one's thoughts or
calling one's mother or father or
presently enjoying time with just one
person who is truly close or enjoying
the night sky quietly with oneself
suddenly become the best and only game
in town
when the calendar is Bearer when the day
is slower when the room is emptier what
is there left to do but the things you
haven't eliminated the things that
matter to you the things that you put
back in the basket
consequently not only is a simpler life
perhaps more enjoyable and of deeper
quality but it is also often more
focused and productive
of course this is all to reduce the
process into simple terms ironically
properly simplifying one's life is
rarely simple but perhaps we can draw
from another philosophy to help us with
this the philosophy of taoism
in taoism there's a concept known as Wu
way which translates into non-doing or
effortless action this is generally
applied to how one carries out work and
tasks suggesting that one engages in
tasks with a deep focus and complete
immersion loosening oneself up and
surrendering to spontaneous action but
we can also apply this same principle
when determining what activities we
participate in to begin with
if we should strive to be less forceful
within our activities perhaps likewise
We should strive to be less forceful
about our activities
going with the flow is often taken to
mean saying yes to everything and just
letting things happen but perhaps a much
more apt interpretation here would mean
only saying yes to things that feel
natural
in other words when considering how to
spend one's time perhaps if it is not
definitely a yes it is definitely a no
in the Taoist text the Dao de Jing Lao
TSU wrote The Supreme good is like water
which nourishes all things without
trying to it is content with the Low
Places that people disdain thus it is
like the Dao in dwelling live close to
the ground in thinking keep to the
simple in governing don't try to control
in work do what you enjoy in family life
be completely present
none of this is to say that a quieter
simpler life is the right life nor a
better life but it is to say that it is
the right better life for some people
and likely lots more people than those
who currently live that way and more yet
a healthy dose of Simplicity and boredom
is still incredibly important and
valuable for everyone of all preferences
and Lifestyles the point is not strictly
to do more or less but to determine what
our lives actually need to maintain the
right flow for some of us perhaps we
genuinely want and need the waters to be
rapid for others however perhaps a
steady current that we can both
comfortably paddle through and
comfortably float in is more than enough
in a world without clear Direction often
far more important than being
influential or world renowned or in a
position of power is simply being sane
and kind
sometimes just being a good decent
person a good friend to a few a
Dependable partner to one a well-focused
participant in a thoughtfully chosen
career is as heroic and successful as
anyone can truly be
perhaps some of the most successful
Among Us are those who very few will
ever know
this video was sponsored by agu1 when
simplifying one's life it's important
that we find solutions to problems that
are as easy as possible without
compromising our goals and needs being
someone who can sometimes struggle with
getting all the proper nutrition ag-1
completely reduces the friction of
hitting health goals getting
comprehensive daily nutrients and
supporting immunity and long-term gut
health in just one scoop and 8 to 12
ounces of water per day ag1 delivers 75
high quality Whole Food sourced
ingredients including vitamins minerals
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens
packing a comprehensive punch of Health
that actually tastes great not only is
ag-1 perfect for both simplifying and
amplifying daily nutrition but it also
serves as a fantastic Catalyst to start
the day starting the morning with the
win for the body is of course a win for
the body but it is also a win for the
day setting one's intentions toward
Health consistency Simplicity and
Effectiveness ag-1's ingredients are
easily absorbed by the the body and
support digestion and gut health which
also helps improve mental Clarity and
sustains your energy throughout the day
making it a perfect Cornerstone to a
healthy routine ag-1 combines nine
Health products into one while making no
compromises and since our physical
health is one of the most important
foundational building blocks to
everything we do we shouldn't make any
compromises either establish the
Cornerstone of your health Journey with
ag-1 by going to athleticgreens.com
pursuit of Wonder to get started on your
order by using my link you'll also
receive a free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D3 and K2 plus 5
travel packs with your first order
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video